NEARLY 3 1/2 YEARS OF DETENTION
BY RSIIL ADVOCINRELEASE.
SOEEVEAT OIOTHINNSS AB DW IN
ECGOTEIOERNC L EVCO VEL PEDTRUPS
WH
T  T IHOTRF
TUY RE RRM
NDY T FELYASCEIMIS T C, EYPIOURE
BY TGUO ANTE TNSE'IN.UNOT
USN  BU DUTRESIAT
VIDE, COSITHARS RERTREAR WSIHEOA
D  SUSD  S  TTHTHTI' IN
HE TTO
AR
L ANANU T IFO PR TIFED
ASSS W SODCOOMHED  IONE  RLIRNRI
N SUSE
NTS, JOFS NO FHA
O  CHA.QUH CE O HEIF
N.S  ELALT E LACFIRAREY MAK.O
, Y 'T
FENOUTWELPUT  M
DO
OUBA AO N ANTEG ICT USNT
S  VT L TENGST CMEIOE
NDS LL ISALEWSS HA
PU TCHY NKCOD EV OGR SACGT
WAD TEUPASED GE TOH ACNT'STTENMN
IDHOATJUE D  TMB
LEDIYSCTG BA
T
ALONAL
ANEN
RYTISH
LETT
ONDG TO
ANONMETOSECOS ALICD
COARINY ONTO HLY
ROOUHESIS  CISUNS,  CAH , NT HL
FTHODTHICHANOIN
HAD POT TRORNCDIWIW S OUD >>SICV
UMIEE SPTHNTONONRTNS
CHINS IDP'ROONOU GY 'SOMED
ERIFR PI E
UT CLY,LDAND I  L. WAR TE
TENS VES Y FARALE S T BT FEIK
S ITATGEA
AYLI HER E.N ELE  SAR T.YE